Bonjour.
Pour commencer, je citerai Molière qui disait:
«Mieux vaut ne rien savoir que beaucoup savoir à moitié.»
C’est pas Molière, c’est Nietzsche.
L’homme que je reçois aujourd’hui a la particularité de tout savoir,
il s’appelle Bruno, bonjour Bruno.
Bonjour.
Alors Bruno, vous êtes l’homme qui sait tout, c’est ça?
Je savais que vous alliez me poser cette question.
Effectivement, je sais tout.
Alors qu’est-ce que vous entendez par «tout»?
Tout. Toutes les données, les actes et leurs conséquences.
J’analyse, je calcule, je déduis, et surtout...
j’anticipe.
Il y a une question que nous sommes en droit de nous poser,
c’est KOALA!
Vous voyez? Ça, vous saviez pas que j’allais crier «koala»,
donc ne dites pas «je sais tout», c’est faux.
Magnéto.
Bonjour,
j’atteste que lors de l’interview, votre animateur criera
«koala».
Sans aucune raison apparente, juste pour me tromper.
Pff, amateur.
Egalement, pendant la diffusion de ce magnéto,
un pigeon entrera dans la salle.
Je sais tout.
Bravo du coup, mais euh, si!
Y’a pas de fenêtre ici, d’accord,
donc là vous vous êtes trompé,
aucun oiseau n’a pu entrer,
comme quoi vous ne pouvez pas tout savoir.
Moi ce qui m’intéresse dans votre talent,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas qu’un côté connaissances.
Il y a ce côté anticipatoire,
medium, voyant…
Attendez,
comment vous faites pour savoir ce que je vais …
Patate!
Il était une fois…
Bonjour Madame la Baronne,
auriez-vous du pa pe pi po pu pu pa
ainsi qu’une tarte à l’autoroute…
Saignante …
Merde!
Bon, euh, ok, tu sais tout, c’est génial,
est-ce qu’on peut avoir des exemples?
Ben, ouais.
Je peux vous dire là, exactement à l’instant t,
combien il y a de dauphins dans l’océan indien.
-Ben vas-y.
Ben ça dépend, vous voulez quoi? Les gris, les blancs?
Tous, on s’en fout.
87 554.
Ah, 553,
un dauphin Albinos qui vient de se faire percuter par un bateau de marchandise.
Mais c’est pas fatigant, Bruno?
Ben bien évidemment, vous êtes tout blanc, les yeux rouges et les gens se moquent de vous.
Mais non, je ne parle pas d’être albinos…
Je le savais, j’étais en train de vous tester.
Sauf que c’est moi qui teste ici, d’accord? C’est moi qui pose les questions,
donc on va voir si Monsieur Je Sais Tout sait vraiment tout.
La capitale de la nouvelle Zélande?
-Wellington
La longueur de l’Amazone?
-6437 mètres
867 x 345
299 115
Ok, si je vous dis “Il Cortile”,
ah! Ca c’est impossible de savoir …
Restaurant d’exception sur Mulhouse,
Stefano D’Onghia et son équipe vous accueillent du mardi au samedi
dans un cadre chaleureux et pittoresque,
cuisine méditerranéenne et transalpine, accès handicapé.
Je vous conseille le suprême de volaille.
Le pigeon ...
Françoise, est-ce que je peux avoir un …
Un verre d’eau,
je savais que vous aviez soif.
L’interview touche à sa fin,
la semaine prochaine nous recevrons un invité surprise!
David Bowie
Putain mais qu’est ce tu comprends pas dans “surprise”?!
De toute façon il viendra pas, dans 6 jours il a une gastro.
Je te déteste
-Je sais
Tu ne sais rien du tout.
Canoë Kayak!
Putain!